[Music]
twist still wait till peak Pro land
spawning he's got the cease and he's
gone
it's all on 2jw smoked oily liquid get
there not to the Grand Slam
and you can forget blast you can forget
Little League game ever again Chicago
you can
you can forget easiest forget the ball
because I here
well guys then about does it for shoe
ease crowd chants that look at you d
monetized and dick Stacy jokes for this
year I am Sydney really had it all great
games great storylines and of course one
of the best crowds in cs:go the only
thing it didn't have is major status
with a capital M a fact not lost on the
Sydney crowd but you know what in many
ways I think I am Sydney would lose a
little something if it actually became a
major and took on all the seriousness
that that entails
I mean cheeky host and an unhinged crowd
that makes for some pretty good times
right so let's not change that anytime
soon
speaking of which here are the best
funny moments and a few fails from IEM
Sydney this year dick jokes and all good
luck predictions in the results to it
okay I like your confidence
I love it I like mean dick I don't about
you guys on the desk meeting yeah yeah
okay yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was the end of this round it's 11 3
is the same hobby as you difficult shots
and easy ones missed as well and it's on
to the same man in another one on four
exists to step wide and it's done
on Mirage well I'm impressed
under breath work we just have to say
that you're fine when you're not really
fine cap right is close that bomb
attempts to be planted and it's maybe
tonight it will be denied scrims
with nowhere else to go falls just like
a bunch of pizza boxes to get right
there they are
we can go tonight guys
for the a pinch - I wanna say to all of
them not gonna lie though you're the
person that knocks it off we're gonna
have to kick you out I'm just saying
sign careful keep going we'll come back
to that later
yeah someone's going home the renegades
Jersey go join renegades he did it thank
you I was born he absolutely does and
there's teammates back stemming from the
a steps as well nitro can cause enough
distraction this could be absolutely
everything Alicia no he's missed the
first
like this that's not bad we'll give that
one an eight out of ten chata cribs nice
life run five no orb available on the CT
side so masters will come out twist mjw
doubt those cereal getting a chart now
it's pretty good it's not bad why do you
love Ariana cause you've been
long-distance for ages you're currently
applying to live together in the States
so why is she worth this long-distance
love even though you like Minecraft
she's pretty cute I mean look at these
teeth now she's just someone is really
special to me that's why today
[Applause]
oh I'm okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
bad fall in the best Bowl and mom
goodness would you believe that oh
what's the matter no cell service ha ha
what's that
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
I want to keep it clean I want to get
the people who've applied a lot of
pressure on me this year I said we got a
win so we're gonna go to the best crack
if you wanted to keep it clean you
wouldn't have brought dick Stacy on this
stage I don't know where he's been but
he looks pretty clean to me
mmm are you clean dick what's going on I
don't hear a thing I was just asking if
you're gonna play a good game all I
wanted to say was uh any women are
looking out there to have a good fun
time tonight room three five three good
more than me and rat wolf come on I'm
just considering the outfit quite
frankly let's head back to the castas
what do you guys think in this round is
fallen part of the scenes for Team UK
it's just frozen to Moses and vote for
Moses you can't expect much and don't
get anything
[Applause]
nice that's a nice they are demolishing
team England they have no answer
nothing can be done they're not even
sure if that ball in himself could turn
this around
only a USP got no kids is he gonna do it
I think you will either let them know
given in Richie the business here we go
[Music]
showed us how it's done well you know
what I say I keep my quote and shaming
them right now they have Zimmerman
absolutely nothing
in fact they will be able to get a bar
together here we go two versus two
starting to dwindle down alive
[Applause]
the winner
and to the victors go the spoils
2017-2018 and now in 2019 with the dick
out in the front it's going to be Team
Australia
[Music]
now of course Sydney wasn't just all fun
and games in fact it gave us one of the
best series of recent memory that is
fnatic vs ni P now we can probably do a
whole video on this rivalry but here are
the best bits from I am Sydney with a
round should be secured head it will
take an absolute miracle when I pee now
to make this round work for them they
have no kit no utility and Swiss gets a
bit unfortunate oh my goodness they'll
be turning around though the collateral
kill comes in and let crow left them at
all to do here all to do a deed bomb
down they know he's coming from a mean
as well and twist finishes it off with a
deagle control of the checkers while he
plays chess twists for kneecaps he'll
find rest get right and worst is gonna
have to be mr. classic on the pistol and
he's got to to find exists already
tagged in the corner checks it and moves
on the clock no less the Glock does not
have the range to the USP it does its
death by a thousand paper cuts if he can
hit every single shot twist can't return
he's got the
[Applause]
vintage inside the site with the bomb
down because he's gotten off the angle
and twist doesn't really need to leave
the site so it's wishful thinking but he
keeps calling
worst is on 2hp boy on anymore he's not
exist found that
luckily lek ro was swift to swing from
the door and bro lands gonna try and be
sneaky to come back through the smoke
bomb plant from yet right above what we
could he thinks get rides gonna try and
wrap back to a name but he pull of an
over Tom sees that 75 easy headshot
potential on that right black crows
gotta be perfect here Rowlands low and
off the edge control leg gets around be
smoke towards heaven just to suggest
they're coming through it and by pull
some rotations over I think it's working
and this is where ni he'd go towards the
a site this has gone very well so far
can they stick the landing JW spots and
absolutely this and he's gonna try and
go above haha does he ever just got
another last swing bomb is dropped in TW
somehow points like bro what a shot up
course want to play overall experience
reign supreme
spotted them
gent like that's one I should be the
game he can't do it three buses to now
big rotation required though both
forests and micro we're both over to
where they let grows the only one going
to the back of the site Forest has
arrived for the bathrooms he'll push
long Dennis just to make sure they can't
plans what a shot through the smoke on
the a K now they can plant them they
have the bathroom but there is a flag
forest is still trying to work in they
want the safety of the truck it's the
only thing that they can delay that's
got micro why don't we to turn this
around
this guy's not a kid anymore what a
coming-of-age on this stage four buses
down and look like the zoo was locked in
as this is the third one the odds seem
low but if it happens for an IP system
cells in what a great position for
Crim's to find that is strong it was
smoked top floors I don't notice that Y
changes again from on stoppage aw brings
us back to a winnable situation now by
God cribs takes away let crow and it's
another huge advantage and I fear thrown
away rest can save the day he currently
has 46 kills to his name look at the
night apart is that enough that should
be a he needs to get the hell out of
there three seven low chance that one
exists
so listen a finish when I see they're
going for it is this gonna be enough as
jwi say so behind with the AWP Crim's is
coming in late this is such a difficult
route as go to put himself in the corner
this work at all last five verses three
now scrims waits there's a gap of the
smoke he makes perfect on it finding rez
he waits as well over step by day get
right at the smoke bombs out 21 seconds
to recover but they've lost the man
advantage more than just some an
advantage it was a five on three and
Crim's single-handedly silences that and
he'll do more twists
he's got forest let go holds by the box
twist drops down he's taken out what
exists is there to trade off of in and
fnatic have brought this back to one how
has he done it the King of Kings Crim's
exists Kenton waited for mistakes he's
got to force them he's got to go on his
own and the corner to find electro who's
not booking easy kill
in the end it's worse on an AWP that has
to try and close this run IP
they had a three ground advantage this
overtime fnatic want to answer it maybe
not so easily done is this dust2 can
forest do it he knows exists is there he
doesn't need to repeat existence to get
aggressive yet again close any room
he'll shut him down he'll go back he's
been the baby's mother he's got the time
this one might be too far gone it is
we're doing
they've got the bomb plant they desire
they have another round into positioning
pushing Telugu that's designed to move
his 8 that's designed to force the reset
hose accuracy and he hits both bullets
ohms cardboard the flashbangs a decent
force hasn't called the first player oh
my god yes he has Brolin goes down and
it's a parole now can fnatic hose it out
forests he's holding the door for now
he's tracking just so well he's not
flicking he's not panicking he's lining
up the shots he's smoking oversold the
double ops on the T side twisted GW is
[Music]
unbelievable the jumping kill to deny
the plan and it's absolutely over that
stage he follows it up with a kill to
watch all as well all the time is back
on the menu he came White Peak which
means he can call it's actually shallow
he could he just didn't get the chance
he might catch DW now he does no mistake
about it man
so when I feet 35 the second floor on
cap they're all gonna go forest isn't
rotating and Norah's cat right he's at
Long alone so put the pressure on light
bro
Molotov on the ramp he's gonna be forced
into goose dropped out Florence
discussed to him
snorts is gonna sneak in this time he's
been so systematic didn't hear it didn't
respond
they were so occupied and committed to
the site and exist make sure to be at
least on the pistol that should always
be enough ten seconds
and twist his busy he's got
Detroit closed it but we've got door
he's got two on the wall not looking and
if he goes now he's got a massive chance
first off any second that quad and twist
down to the team
and fnatic turning around
fanatic made their way to the semi-final
that's got to be one of the most
exciting games I've ever casted so much
action so much drama and so much emotion
as well this Swedish Darby it normally
delivers but this was something that go
down in history one of the greatest
counter-strike games
now of course incredible plays were not
limited to El Clasico at IEM Sydney so
here are the best plays from the rest of
the tournament defense position Jacob
what an information as low as any I
guess is gonna be unchecked so yeah
here's this opportunity to drink I
wonder what he's Friday on and that
should be the round this 30 seconds
remaining that is the 2v3 so Randy gates
with the man advantage on the back of a
huge spray jacket
daddy's sorry rotations in effect boy oh
man oh man with Kerrigan solo he does
well to find one to find for a second on
the flank though I'm not sure have to
worry about it just yet as he backs up
becomes but it doesn't even matter its
lucky it down he's got three from four
he's got bit range
he ended the first half with 19 Rob
spines 23 still I just baby after Ward
coos all of my saw has to hold this game
Thursday after the support text to take
again yank oh that's a nice way to start
has been able to find all of my sister
as well with double entry from Dexter
gives them the room to breathe air pipe
lines them up that is a little bit
fortunate on the timing one falling down
one jumping up and straight in the
middle of both of them
12 seconds he's gonna try and get above
as well that's big of the better angles
dozen squad anyone bombs got to be
planted Ethan to do at GW doesn't have
position to wrap on it so they can't
deny that was probably their best chance
I say that until twist shows up sir to
clutch it back with an AWP a twist has
an 8k picked up he might be low on HP
but he's getting a lot closer
to position but GW reads it wrong
thoughts irked my wrap around and twist
he didn't have enough flat for the fight
break the glass or open the door
by the way it sound cute given to MIB
are and or how good was that oh that is
unreal
breezy he masks the sound with also the
upper windows be broken and he's gonna
find a free kill because of it he might
find to know the trigger discipline not
there and he will shut down Tarko fallen
does go down in the end and that is a
gamer moment for players on a white now
here's white now but still finds kills
nearly a tizzy and dropping into his
crosshair as well hsk now has the
information and zion has not yet been
spotted in the corner which should mean
should mean success for him not if next
gets to be slow with steady and tapping
away all these headshots so the chance a
slim one but for something there there's
the first shot slow it down now and it's
a 1vs1 set way towards the quad my god
next that is absolutely wonderful
look at this though from taco he's been
spotted by Carrigan caldera beeps in
through bathrooms that's not the kind of
guy you want to meet there two players
down now and we're back to 3b too so
salvageable for MIB our smoke comes down
onto the backside of the site
Molly onto the truck make it start to
creep fairway in here MIB are still a
little bit of time to play with the
flashbang over mousesports
is good give the info across caldera
through the smoke absolutely terrorizing
now sports at this point but carrying
and drops the bomb carrier to which Colt
arrow of course replies and he's on for
the ACE now for kills already four
coldzera
can he find rocks decides not to plant
the form but he's going to have to
eventually he can do it safe finding as
much time as he possibly can and rocks
may miss the one opportunity that he
needed because coldzera
you don't doubt him in a situation like
this or one be one
it's his home terror
it's the ice clutch this just nitro here
can culture with the aim tool
nope Wow I mean what do you even say
about that it is only 47 your baby
carrot in the corner Chris Jason you
gotta scale Oh BJ finish it off off if
he hits the head he definitely can't
stay alive as well drop into the sand
with as well as a shutdown brought
around from Chris J 3 with the scat
almost the fourth as well all signed
attempt on for the ice it's up to layers
to stop him and he does he will be
flanked out by rocks with the unto
players coming in through market colds
gonna have to deal with them on the site
and Phelps can't get caught out of
position but he does ruts finds it's all
I'm cold on the bomb site we've seen him
clutch here before though
exactly can he do it once again here for
MIB are in such a critical round will
mousesports even give him that
opportunity as they start to filter
their way on to the bomb site all
together they're peaking the wrong
angles called Sarah has a chance now to
of fallen and a Thompson throws that he
kept the doctor
what before for Ethan up close to the
smoke maybe gives them more confidence
on the spray they're very similar in
that regard
I have no answer for Dino Liam attempted
to search tries desperately to get the
shot back from this without consider in
the open and vulnerable three down and
two to five make it just watch G W is
for quad friends is boosted nobody's
gonna let them go oh this is a slaughter
an absolute slaughter he's got the wrong
disc got two kills for it he finds three
in the ends spots two more as well and
now in nitros position becomes massive
because he opens the door and catches
one of the backline it's all on the bro
later drops the bomb Crim's against Stu
you know one on one 11 seconds he can't
get to the ball it's good for the board
they couldn't win it if he finds him in
the smoke but now to get 14 crisp clean
lock boys doesn't get more portion not
sure he's aware of it now he'll be taken
down it's up to twist who has been quiet
so far but he's found the bomb Nitro 2
vs. 1 AWP use the mods off to flush out
twist on the other side but the back
step comes in Jessie hit the heck shot
this one off the clock headshot followed
up by the offshore and it's twist this
low one put on an eva side we'll do it
one we'll do it on either side but
doctors still gonna stand in the OP I
can't believe he hit that headshot on
reaction spinning around twist now has
to dance backwards to find better ground
to rotate officers nitro 2 has no idea
as to get the angle watch from lights
it all starts with a bit of a chance
Shawn I have to say I've got a Lachlan
he'll take it I'm old ready to jewel as
a flash of a middle-grade flash but I
find the headshots that already ruled
damage but a second bite of the cherry
proton you'll find three in total that
is something quite special well guys
that about does it for the best of IEM
Sydney now if you want to see more
content like this like the video sub to
the channel and comment below it's
honestly the best way to keep us making
these csgo videos and uh one more thing
Aussie Aussie Aussie that was nice
see you next time thanks for watching if
you want more great content just like
this be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]